you celebrated your 93rd birthday and
the Hot in Cleveland the whole the cast
the crew everybody of Hot in Cleveland
had a flash mob to celebrate it was a
surprise flash mob for your birthday it
was such a surprise and such fun the
person who drove me dropped me off way
over here and I said why are we doing
this they said well they're they're
shooting on your street today so yeah we
have to but you'll be picked up so a
golf cart came by and picked me up and I
thought oh this is swell so and all of a
sudden we drove around and people kept
coming out of all the offices and all
the studios and everything they all just
kept coming out until we had a whole mob
there and we went all over the lot it
was it I haven't come down saying no
I've had that happen to me but it's
people trying to attack me yeah yeah
Rolling Stones yeah yeah pitchforks the
whole torches the whole thing we have a
clip from this this is pretty impressive
this is fun take a look
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos